[Music]  there's all these beautiful women whose  I just talking to Wow this definitely  sets the scene for romance you know they  go better than winter games right how  does to you I'm excited like this is my  year people everywhere I mean not a bad  situation to be in right with that  usually when there's this many  attractive people of the opposite sex  all together I go down waiting for  Colton to come out that's gonna happen  wait for that - yeah you keep like  looking over there hoping he might come  I think that Pia is I think she's a  sweetheart but seems like Tia came here  for Colton so Colton here I saved you a  seat it's right next to you okay that's  that he's gonna walk down the stairs  [Music]